-- Captions by VITAC --
www.vitac.com
WELCOME TO CNN TONIGHT.
I'M JAKE TAPPER IN WASHINGTON
AND TONIGHT, THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA VERSUS A FAR-RIGHT
MILITIA ACCUSED OF TRYING TO
OVERTURN THE GOVERNMENT.
PERHAPS ITS BIGGEST TEST YET.
FEDERAL PROSECUTORS TODAY
RESTED A HISTORIC CASE AGAINST
FIVE ELECTED LEADERS --
INCLUDING ITS FOUNDER FOR THE
ROLE IN THE U.S. CAPITOL ATTACK
ON JANUARY 6TH 2021.
OVER THE LAST MONTH, THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT PRESENTED
WITNESS TESTIMONY AND SHOCKING
VIDEOS, AND DAMNING TEXT
MESSAGES, AND MORE.
ALL OF IT, EVIDENCE THAT
PROSECUTORS SAY, PROVES THE
FIVE DEFENDANTS ATTEMPTED TO
CARRY OUT A COORDINATED
CONSPIRACY TO STOP THE LEGAL
AND LAWFUL TRANSFER OF
PRESIDENTIAL POWER, AND KEEP
DONALD TRUMP IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
NOW WHY IS THIS CASE?
SO DIFFERENT THAN THE HUNDREDS
OF OTHER CASES FACING ALLEGED
JENNER SIX RIOTERS AND
INSURRECTIONISTS?
TWO WORDS, SEDITIOUS CONSPIRACY.
THAT'S A RARE CHARGE, ONE BUT
ON THE BOOKS AROUND THE CIVIL
WAR, WHEN THE CONFEDERACY
DECLARED WAR ON THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT.
IT'S A CHARGE RESERVE FOR ONLY
THE BRAVEST OF THREATS TO THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT.
THESE FIVE ALLEGED OATH KEEPERS
ARE THE FIRST TO STAND TRIAL
FOR THIS ACCUSATION IN MORE
THAN A DECADE.
THE REALLY UNDERSTAND THIS CASE,
YOU GOT FIRST UNDERSTAND WHO
AND WHAT THE OATH KEEPERS ARE,
THAT THE GROUP WAS FOUNDED BY
THIS GUY, STEWART RHODES IN
2009.
RHODES IS AN ANTI GOVERNMENT
EXTREMISTS, ARMY VETERAN AND
DISBARRED LAWYER, WHO
ACCIDENTALLY SHOT AT HIS OWN
EYE SEVERAL WEEKS AGO.
ACCORDING TO ITS FORMER WEBSITE,
THE OATH KEEPERS ARE A
NONPARTISAN ASSOCIATION OF
CURRENT AND FORMALLY SERVING
MILITARY, POLICE AND FIRST
RESPONDERS WHO PLEDGED TO
FULFILL THE OLD ALL MILITARY
POLICE INTAKE TO DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION AGAINST ALL
ENEMIES FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC,
UNQUOTE.
TRANSLATED, WHAT THAT MEANS IS,
THEY THINK THEY DON'T HAVE TO
FOLLOW ANY ORDERS FROM ANY
GOVERNMENT THAT THEY THINK IS
ILLEGITIMATE, SUCH AS OUR
CURRENT DEMOCRATIC WE ELECTED
ONE.
>> YOU GOT TO DECLARE
EVERYTHING THAT COMES OUT OF
KING BIDEN'S MOUTH AS A
LEGITIMATE AND NULL AND VOID
FROM THE INCEPTION, HE'S NOT A
LEGITIMATE PRESIDENT.
>> SO, LET'S GO INSIDE THE
COURTROOM NOW AND EXAMINE THE
CASE SO FAR.
PROSECUTORS SAY THAT RHODES,
ALONG WITH KELLY MEGS, JESSICA
WALK-INS, KENNETH HARRISON AND
THOMAS CALDWELL, PLANNED FOR
AND ARMED REBELLION LONG BEFORE
JANUARY SIX, AND THAT THEY WERE
PREPARED TO DO ANYTHING
NECESSARY TO KEEP JOE BIDEN AT
THE WHITE HOUSE.
PROSECUTORS ALLEGE THAT MEMBERS
OF THE OATH KEEPERS ATTENDED
RALLIES IN D.C. IN NOVEMBER AND
DECEMBER OF 2020 AS, QUOTE,
TYRANTS.
HERE IS WHAT RHODES SAID IN
DECEMBER 2020 AT ONE OF THE
EVENTS, AS HE TRIED TO
ENCOURAGE PRESIDENT TRUMP TO
FIGHT TO STAY IN OFFICE.
>> IF HE DOES NOT DO IT NOW,
WHILE HE IS COMMANDER IN CHIEF,
WE'LL HAVE TO DO IT OURSELVES
LATER IN A MUCH MORE DESPERATE,
MUCH MORE BLOODY WAR.
>> MUCH MORE DESPERATE, MUCH
MORE BLOODY WAR.
THEY WERE DRESSED FOR THAT
BLOODY WAR THE NEXT MONTH,
JANUARY SIX.
OATH KEEPERS DECKED OUT IN FULL
BATTLE GEAR, SEEN MOVING
THROUGH THE MOB PURPOSEFULLY,
ENTERING THE CAPITOL.
PROSECUTORS SAY THAT MEG
HARRISON AND WATKINS ARE PART
OF THE STACK FORMATION, WHICH
JOINED A MOB OF PEOPLE, SOME OF
WHOM WERE ATTACKING POLICE
OFFICERS.
--
A QRF, THAT'S WHAT IT'S CALLED
IN THE MILITARY.
AT A HOTEL INSIDE WASHINGTON
D.C., WITH OTHER MEMBERS
CARRYING FIREARMS, STANDING BY
TO JOIN HIS BLOODY WAR, IF
NECESSARY.
PROSECUTORS SAY THOSE QRF TEAMS
WERE COORDINATED IN PART BY
THOMAS CALDWELL, THE FIFTH
DEFENDANT ON TRIAL FOR NOW.
TODAY, THE DEFENSE BEGAN TO
PRESENT ITS CASE, AND WE HAVE
GOTTEN A GLIMPSE INTO THE
STRATEGY ALREADY.
DESENSITIZE ARGUE THAT OATH
KEEPERS NEVER HAD A SPECIFIC
PLAN ON JANUARY SIX, AND THAT
RHODES NEVER EXPLICITLY
INSTRUCTED THE GROUP TO THE
CAPITOL.
THE DEFENSE ATTORNEYS ALSO SAY
THAT THE OATH KEEPERS WERE
NONVIOLENT DURING THE RIGHT,
AND THEY THEMSELVES NEVER
CALLED IN THEIR QUICK REACTION
FORCES, THEIR QRFS.
OBVIOUSLY, PROSECUTORS
DISAGREED.
I THINK THE OATH KEEPERS WERE
CONSPIRING FOR MUCH MORE THAN
THEY ACTUALLY CARRIED OUT ON
THAT DAY, HENCE THE CHARGE OF
SEDITIOUS CONSPIRACY.
SO WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
WHAT DOES THE STATUTE OF THE
U.S. FEDERAL LAW?
WHY DOES IT EXIST?
WELL, AS I TOLD YOU, IT DATES
BACK TO 1861 AND THE U.S. CIVIL
WAR.
CONGRESS MADE IT A CRIME TO
CONSPIRE TO OVERTHROW THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT OR TO CONSPIRE TO
USE FORCE TO, QUOTE, PREVENT,
HINDER OR DELAY THE EXECUTION
OF ANY LAW OF THE UNITED STATES.
THE CONFEDERATE INSURRECTIONIST
FAILED, THOUGH IT TOOK FOUR
YEARS TO STOP THEIR ARMED
REBELLION.
AND THE SEDITIOUS CONSPIRACY
CHARGE HAS REALLY BEEN USED
SINCE.
IT WAS USED NOTABLY IN 1954
AGAINST TERRORIST PUSHING
PUERTO RICAN INDEPENDENTS.
>> RESTLESS, FANATIC VIOLENCE
ERUPTED IN THE HALLS OF
CONGRESS.
THREE MEN BELIEVED TO BE PART
OF A PUERTO RICAN GAME, IN 1950,
ATTEMPTED ASSASSINATION OF
PRESIDENT TRUMAN, OPENED FIRE
FROM THE VISITORS GALLERY ON
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
ESTIMATES OF THE NUMBER OF
SHOTS FIRED RANGED FROM 15 TO
30, AND EACH BULLET HOLE FOUND
AS A GRIM REMINDER TO THOSE
THAT WERE PRESIDENT OF THE
TERRIBLE SURPRISE ATTACK.
>> IN THAT ATTACK ON THE
CAPITOL, FIVE CONGRESSMAN WERE
SHOT AND WOUNDED, BUT
THANKFULLY, ALSO RIGHT.
THOSE SUSPECTS WERE CONVICTED
ON CHARGES OF SEDITIOUS
CONSPIRACY.
THE LAST TIME THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT BROUGHT THOSE
CHARGES AND ONE THE CASE WAS IN
1995, WHEN AN EGYPTIAN CLERK --
NINE OF HIS FOLLOWERS WERE
CONVICTED IN A PLOT TO BLOW UP
THE UNITED NATIONS AND OTHER
BUILDING.
LOOK, EXPERTS SAY THAT THE
BROAD NATURE OF THE SEDITIOUS
CONSPIRACY LAW CAN BE DIFFICULT
TO SO TO A JURY.
IN 1988, A JURY ACQUITTED A
GROUP OF WHITE SUPREMACY IS
ACCUSED OF PLOTTING TO
OVERTHROW THE GOVERNMENT AND
ESTABLISH AN ALL WHITE NATION.
TEN YEARS AGO, A JUDGE JUST
DISMISSED A CASE AGAINST A
MICHIGAN MILITIA, ACCUSED OF
PLOTTING AN ATTACK ON THE
FOREFRONT.
ALL THAT RAISES THE STAKES FOR
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TODAY.
IN THIS TRIAL, AGAINST THE OATH
KEEPERS AND ITS UPCOMING TRIAL
AGAINST A DIFFERENT FAR-RIGHT
GROUP, THE PROUD BOYS.
LOOK, JANUARY SIX WAS CREW IN
EFFORT TO STOP THE PEACEFUL
TRANSFER OF POWER, BUT
PROSECUTORS ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO PROVE AND CONVINCE A JURY
THAT IT WAS COORDINATED.
AS EVIDENCED BY THE ATTACK ON
PAUL PELOSI LAST WEEK OR THE
ATTEMPTED ATTACK ON A SUPREME
COURT JUSTICE, BRETT KAVANAUGH,
A FEW MONTHS AGO, DOMESTIC
EXTREMIST VIOLENCE IS A REAL
THREAT.
A STUDY EARLIER THIS YEAR FROM
THE ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE
REVEALS, QUOTE, RIGHT WING
EXTREMISTS WILLING TO --
26 EXTREMIST-RELATED MURDERS IN
THE UNITED STATES IN 2021 AND
HAVE BEEN RESPONSIBLE FOR 75%
OF SUCH MURDERS IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS, UNQUOTE.
THIS HAS BEEN BUILDING FOR
YEARS.
REMEMBER THE UNITE THE RIGHT
GATHERING OF RACIST AND
EXTREMISTS IN CHARLOTTESVILLE?
LOOK, BACK IN 2020, AT THE
FIRST PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE, OUR
OWN CHRIS WALLACE DIRECTLY
ASKED THEN PRESIDENT TRUMP IF
HE WAS WILLING TO CONDEMN WHITE
SUPREMACISTS AND FAR-RIGHT
GROUPS SUCH AS THE PROUD BOYS.
DO YOU MEMBER TRUMP'S RESPONSE?
>> PROUD BOYS, STAND BACK AND
STAND BY.
>> STAND BACK AND STAND BY.
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT PROSECUTORS
SAY THE EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT
THESE FAR-RIGHT GROUPS WERE
STANDING BY.
THEY WERE WAITING FOR A GREEN
LIGHT TO UNDERMINE DEMOCRACY
AND ALLOW TRUMP TO HOLD ON TO
POWER.
AS THE JANUARY 6TH SELECT
COMMITTEE --
THERE WERE CONNECTIONS BETWEEN
MEMBERS OF THESE FAR-RIGHT
GROUPS AND FOLKS IN DONALD
TRUMP'S ORBIT, PEOPLE LIKE
ROGER STONE OR MICHAEL FLYNN.
I ASKED TRUMP'S FORMER
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR, ALYSSA
FARAH GRIFFIN, WHY?
>> THE ONLY REASON YOU WOULD BE
TALKING TO THOSE GROUPS BECAUSE
YOU WANTED A VIOLENT PRESENCE
AT THE CAPITOL THAT DAY.
>> DONALD TRUMP COULD TODAY
RIGHT NOW ISSUE A CLEAR AND
UNEQUIVOCAL CONDEMNATION OF THE
OATH KEEPERS AND THE PROUD BOYS
AND WHAT THEY TRIED TO DO THAT
THERE.
YOU'D THINK THAT CONDEMNING
WOULD BE TERRORISTS CHARGED BY
THE U.S. DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
WOULD SEDITIOUS CONSPIRACY
WOULD NOT BE DIFFICULT.
ASK YOURSELF, WHY HASN'T HE?
DO YOU MEMBER WHAT THE FORMER
SPOKESPERSON FOR THE OATH
KEEPERS FOR THE JANUARY SIX
COMMITTEE A FEW MONTHS AGO?
>> IF A PRESIDENT THAT IS
WILLING TO TRY TO INSTILL --
ENCOURAGE, TO WHIP UP A CIVIL
WAR AMONGST HIS FOLLOWERS USING
LIES AND DECEIT AND SNAKE